marché fary crohn promener dans la
nature avec ses animaux de compagnie ma
tortue mon chien mon poisson rouge
[Musique]
j'ai aussi organisés j'ai fait un peu de
méditation est un biogaz offre un peu de
respiration et je pensais que j'allais
prendre quelques kilos basse temps
enfermé et au final j'ai pris quelques
kilos
on reste enfermé mais j'ai minimisé les
choses faisant très attention à ce que
je mange
c'était ma première résolution document
ce qui m'a surpris positivement cdma
capacité à m'organiser en fait j'ai
jamais autant travaillé que pendant ce
confinement merci de télétravail comme
j'écris les articles dans télé star télé
poche télé magazine people elle et sa
supérieure en numérique par une avocate
au sénat pub ça te permet de te
concentrer et d'avoir un objectif donc
donnez vous des objectifs
venez voir planning et c'est pour moi la
meilleure façon de faire passer les
choses alors mais la solution poste
confinement allez faire un tour et
disneyland avec mes amis avec les
chroniqueurs de tnt et pourquoi pas et
surtout prendre l'air marché farik ron
promenades dans la nature avec ses
animaux de compagnie d'abord pourquoi
seront j ai bien coûter voici mon lieu
où se faire de méditation monsieur sisi
il a cessé mon blond de voix tranquille
je peux me concentrer et j'ai comme j'ai
une connexion wifi assez merdique vous
le dire si une vidéo drôle je lui sur
les réseaux sociaux
c'est cette petite fille qui pleure l
idée ne pas pouvoir se faire livrer en
maktoum kfc balduf certes mais c'est
très drôle et c'est le sun qui a partagé
cette vidéo regarde
[Musique]
je suis plus d'être flic cents chez eux
je conseille le film à la plate forme un
mélange entre le thriller la science
fiction c'est vraiment très intéressant
refait tous les frames par la même
occasion
et puis plein de série romantique hyper
joli à voir
je ne bois pas d'alcool
donc au final un petit et comme la reine
d'angleterre avec un petit peu dit cuma
qui sont sucrés tenait ce qui nous
permet d'avoir un teint frais vous avez
vu le résultat est le quitter
ni l'un ni l'autre je n'ai jamais aussi
peu regardé la télévision en fait
j'essaye de m'informer de manière très
cohérente et pas rester toute la journée
sur les chaînes d'information sap tels
besoins en énergie donc chaque gens
regardent le ce qu'il faut retenir en 10
15 minutes et après je me coupe des
médias et des reconversions un peu
anxiogène
j'essaye de me changer les idées c'est
le plus important se changer les idées
et regardez il ya un super programme qui
s'appelle ce soir sur baba faire sept
minutes de sport par jour j'ai
téléchargé une application gratuite qui
permet de faire ça c'est pas énorme
les sept jours sur plusieurs jours là et
les petits fr les livres tout athlète de
chou blanc s'est pas totalement son
corps
[Applaudissements]